so once you get to the point where the
cat's out of the bag
every conversation you have with her has
to be recorded no matter
i mean like what does she do like did
she try to pin this on you this was your
fault
did she did she point and blame you for
all this like well it was
it was denial at first you know and of
course
i'm not you know at that process and
during that point of the process
she's just been served i'm not going to
let the cat out of the bag on what i
have
yet that's got you know um so
she you know where are you getting this
how are you getting this information
well you know i stumbled across a couple
messages on your phone
uh what are you doing to my phone well
you know you misread something it was
probably me just joking around with one
of my friends we sent ourselves dirty
jokes all the time
you know yadda yadda um
and it and she was clever enough in the
in the phone by the way when i stumbled
across the messages
they were on in her phone as female
friends by the way
um so she didn't have the the contacts
saved is like a male's name it was like
a girl's name yeah it was like becky
smith or something exactly
and and that's that's what was strange
because
when i initially opened the phone um i
thought to myself
well she's texting her she hasn't even
hung out with her forever why is she
texting her
right and of course of course i pop pop
open the message and i'm going well i
mean it was
confusion at first because i'm like you
know what the heck i mean she's what
what's going on with her female friend
but of course it was just you know she
she hid the names on her phone so you
got to kind of be
cautious of those those tricks as well
you